hey guys Mary here with GameSpot
presents the mix at GDC 2016 I'm here
with Daniel hey how's it going and well
awesome and you were here from data
realms and you'll be showing me
planetoid pioneers from a which is
online kind of adventure sandbox game
set in space oh yeah it doesn't space
we'll talk about the context in a second
but yeah it's it's a futuristic kind of
sci-fi thing sweet so let's actually get
right into it and show me what you're
working with here sounds good
can they see the screen yeah thank you I
can wonderful so yeah there's plenty of
fun ears is something we've worked on
for seven years now most of the time
went into the the physics engine that
we'd built from scratch as you can see
these creatures are battling it out
right now the title screen they are
completely physics driven and the damage
is also caused dynamically so that's
something that we work on for a very
long time we also worked on these tools
that I hope to show today so planetary
pioneers as you can tell on the name
plays out on different planet tides and
each planet has its own or planetoid has
its own little kind of self-contained
game worlds and that you can actually
make yourself there's a robot trying to
help he's good anyway so the context of
the game is for this specific planetoid
the scenarios that this old guy who's
out in space and his Bates yacht he it
blows up for whatever reason and he has
to emergency land on this planet toy and
it's a you know he's an old guy he's
like 200 years old because in the future
we're gonna have medical tech advances
that let us live for a very long time
and we get bored of Earth and we have
the technology to empower us to go out
into space and actually explore you know
this stuff in in the solar system so far
you know the kind of asteroid belts and
so on so this guy just crash landed on
this planetoid it's actually a large
large rock amazing two and a half
kilometers in circumference
and there's a surface but there's also
these cave complexes that you're
exploring so it's kind of like the Zelda
overworld is the surface and then you go
into these cave complexes that you have
to progressively get you know to the
harder and harder ones so we have
all the wreckage here from my for my
thing that blew up you know as I landed
yeah I can absorb the resources from
that and as you see our physics engine
is showing off you know that we can we
can dynamically destroy and absorb the
metals carbon water and silicon
resources out of this wreckage and with
those I can then build whatever I want
that I have a let's see if I can get
that going yeah so we have all the
different blueprints here so whatever
you have a blueprint for and you have
the resources for you can actually build
so we get the blueprints so you get them
by finding vehicles or whatever you come
across as soon as you start absorbing
something you get the blueprint for it
as well so when you find now I just
cheat it and I got all the blueprints
but I just built a vehicle here and I
can go into it and drive it around this
is literally the crappiest vehicle there
is it'll break very quickly and yeah so
I can just jump out okay it's a piece of
junk right so I just recycle it and I
get the resources back out of it and I
can build something else so one of the
one of the big gameplay mechanics here
is that the challenge is not find only
finding the resources but is actually
moving them around around the planetoid
so I'm gonna cheat again and get all the
resources I can so you can build this
Lowell golem which actually this is a
little helper robot right so he's
actually a 1 ton of metal so if I ever
need one ton of metal he will follow me
around and this is a way for me to
actually move resources around I could
use you know vehicles to move them
around oh I'm on fire and it crashed
that's good I will run again now this is
still early in development what time
what we like framer you in yeah so we're
we're gonna be releasing an early access
on Steam next month so April 5th 15 is
actually sorry and we're excited about
that because we're doing something kind
of interesting with early access instead
of trying to create a modern community
we are trying to create a contributor
community and the way that works is
we're thinking about it where instead of
mods where people get to tinker with a
game after it's done I might as well go
into the editing of this right now you
know to show that off we want to empower
them with tools to build a game
alongside with us so in
early access typically you just get you
know people giving a verbal feedback on
what you know they want to see developed
in the game as you as you move along
right but here we've built these tools
over seven years that I'm about to start
showing you guys that will put in the
hands of anyone who buys the early
access version and we would love for the
best of that content that hopefully
people will use make with those tools to
be put into the official game so people
can get you know credit in the game and
they can also sell their items on the
workshop on Steam Workshop so there's
very powerful tools that I'm gonna start
messin with right now just to show you
guys so I'm kind of stuck in this pit
here and I realized as a game designer
this is not the best kind of design for
this level so I'm just gonna go in and
start editing right away I can just move
move this corner up oops sorry
I'm missing this Mouse's okay there you
go so that's good I'm just gonna make
this kind of level design change here
and this widget is not letting you
select it what I'm gonna uh that's funky
um here we go so I'm I just built a
different world oak einde of part of the
level here I can I can make copies of
this and move it around and you can go
back to playing it yes so if I um pause
here it'll actually pop me out and now I
can run up this hill that I just created
so that's you know the level the level
itself you know I can drag in any image
that I that I want into the game and
it'll if I restart the level it'll still
be the change will be preserved so you
know the the scenes and the planetoids
themselves you can build and you can
share very easily with your friends
they're also the blueprints that we
talked about before everything in the
game is a blueprint so if you want to
edit any of those things like any of
these robots or creatures you can
absolutely just fire them up everything
you've seen in this game so far
was built in these tools so if I want to
change the head of this guy like
everything about him is is in here so if
I select his helmet and okay I want to
put a different texture on him right I
can go with this internal you know like
texture editor I can go in and look at
all this stuff and nothing is watered
down this is not like something that is
like a big planet or something I can get
Arnold in here if I want to you know
like no Arnie's okay no you can say that
and then we can just restart you know
the level with Arnie running around his
head is a little big but you know you
can adjust that's so yeah now you're
playing as Arnie they're really really
interesting pardon if I can can I do not
pull screen and would that screw up the
stream you think it will look funky you
think full screen okay oh that's that's
right we'll just do this I can also drag
in pictures off of slack we're off of
the internet - actually they get stuff
into the game I don't know if this is
gonna work in this stream is that what
there's okay well that's good so we're
we're golden then but yeah you can you
can drag in textures from you know now I
have my own head we were working on your
head we took a picture of you earlier
but I think quite managed to get in
there so you could probably feel
relieved about that but yeah so now you
know we have this guy who has a gigantic
head which is even better you know more
appropriate for myself but yeah it's a
you could put this in the world itself
yeah exactly so this picture that I just
dragged in an office lack which is just
a browser I can save you know this guy
and now you know this this if I reset
and unpause you know wow so my head got
dragged in today now it's a part of the
scene and that's like a super bizarre
nightmare going on here but you get the
idea that also when when you save one of
these blueprints you can actually drag
them into slack and upload them that way
and everything about that blueprint all
about the creature and the vehicle or
whatever you build it gets saved into
that PNG files so if it's in that file I
can drag it into slack and everything
about it is there so anyone else can
then download it and just drag it into
the game like this and have a battle of
bots or whatever they want to do with
those creatures like right off the bat
because it's all self-contained in that
in the blueprint oh that's great people
can make whatever they want how many
do you have like a lot of creatures to
start the game off wait for it already
yeah so we we buy launched not only have
we built we've spent a bunch of time
building stuff ourselves yeah we will do
and we've we've spent a lot of time
building you know all these all these
different blueprints we're also gonna
have our contributor community that we
already started we have 4,000 people in
our private beta we're gonna challenge
them over the next month that we're also
gonna be streaming on Twitch where they
are gonna be able to submit you know
whatever they build with these tools
that we've already put in their hands
and they're gonna fill out you know the
workshop and have all this stuff that is
available already so yeah it's it's
gonna be a good amount of content from
the beginning but we really want to have
the early access period be a period
where people are contributing and adding
to the game and we'll be curating kind
of making a cohesive experience out of
that so well thanks Daniel for showing
me that was a planetoid of pioneers
which is going to be when Windows Mac
and Linux yes pretty soon on early
access that's right
thank you so much thank you very much
you